how about some teams that have more work
to do over the balance of the 2021
off-season shireen i'll give you the
first crack at identifying a team that
needs to do more work and why
well we talked about washington having
one of the better off seasons in the nfc
i would say the cowboys still have a lot
of work to do to improve on their
offseason they did accomplish their
biggest goal which was resigning dak
press got to a long-term deal i'll give
them that one but as far as improving
this roster i don't know that they've
done that so far mike they've just not
made a lot of moves yes they've resigned
jordan lewis yeah he's your nickel
corner okay they signed uh safety uh ken
keanu neal they got him he may play
outside linebacker for him we'll see
what they do with him they got a backup
offensive tackle they just haven't done
a whole lot you saw how much the backup
quarterback was important to them last
year they don't have that they lost andy
dalton and they still need a ton of
defensive help i mean this is a
franchise that that set the franchise
record for points allowed in a season
473 points they gave up they were
horrible at stopping the run they've
neglected the three technique and
they've neglected the safety position
forever so they have got to improve at
both of those positions so we know last
year they passed up the getting
defensive help in the first round pick
when cd lamb fell to him i have a hard
time arguing that cd lamb wasn't the
pick there but they've got to do a
better job of getting
defensive help in this draft if they're
going to be a better team on the field
this year
yeah i i i agree with you completely and
i still continue to have misgivings
about how they handled dak prescott as i
explained it in a post yesterday they
waited too long and then they didn't
wait long enough i i i and
that that that that cap money could have
gone to address other areas i'm a little
surprised they retained ezekiel elliott
and guaranteed his salary for next year
this is just a team that
i
i i
i know that every year there's this
sense that on paper they're going to be
really good but it just i feel like
there is more that they need to do there
are more weaknesses than they will ever
admit and i think what happens is when
you are so premised on hyping and hyping
and hyping your team sometimes you start
to believe the hype instead of
acknowledging where the very real flaws
are and getting to work on addressing
them the seahawks have tried to address
some of their weaknesses i just i'm
looking at the list of the free agents
they've signed and i just
you know it's
i don't want to be disrespectful to
these players but there's there's nobody
they've signed
that makes me say
wow that is going to make all the
difference wow that guy's going to make
all the difference i'm not saying they
should have overpaid to keep shaquille
griffin at corner who signed a
three-year deal what 45 million ish i
think with the jacksonville jaguars it's
hard not to have all these numbers blend
together but you know a couple of pass
rushers okay carrie hyder wasn't bad but
i i
i just between that and the lingering
question of what russell wilson wants
and does he want to be part of the team
and are they going to
reconfigure their overall philosophy to
cater to russell wilson i just feel like
this team is kind of in quicksand and
they've got their hands on a rope and
we're not quite sure whether they're
going to be able to pull themselves out
of it i feel like that's where they are
right now and there's nothing they've
done in the season that screams out
upgrade that screams out we're taking
the next step we're moving to the next
level they kept chris carson well
there's a reason chris carson wasn't
pounced upon by other teams he's a
running back who can't stay healthy you
can't bank on a running back who can't
stay healthy and this isn't a criticism
some running backs can stay healthy some
can't it's a difficult position to play
guys get injured
some guys are just
constituted differently than others and
they can take that pounding they they
need a marshawn lynch they can't find a
marshawn lynch so they renew their vows
with chris carson and what hope that he
all of a sudden after years of wear and
tear is going to be better equipped to
avoid being injured as he
puts more wear and tear on his on his
body i i just
for a team that i still think will be a
playoff contender and likely make the
playoffs because of pete carroll
i look at the pieces and i say you got
to do more if you want to be more than
just a team that makes it to the wild
card round and maybe if you're lucky
gets to the divisional round
well and i go back mike to to what
russell wilson said right after the
season which i want to see this
offensive line upgraded did gabe jackson
alone do that
i assume they're going to spend some
draft picks on some offensive linemen
and maybe sign some other free agents
out there but i don't know that there's
going to be any free agents out there
who are going to come in and help this
offensive line so i don't know that
they've upgraded the one position that
russell wilson said he wanted to see
them
improve upon right mike i just don't
know that gabe jackson it makes that hu
big of a difference for russell wilson
to keep him from getting sacked a record
number of times
yeah and the bottom line is the raiders
didn't want to keep gabe jackson for a
reason all right give me another team
shireen that needs more to do more work
well guess what mike the packers signed
their first free agent today and their
second free agent today and the first
one was a long snapper i never heard of
and the reason is he's never played in
the nfl before so
they did get a tight end in
mercedes-lewis but this is a team that
just hasn't done anything and again you
go back to aaron rodgers comments at the
end of the season about wanting to have
a say in personnel and upgrade to me the
best move they've made is keep aaron
jones but again we're talking about a
running back you can find running backs
i know he fits our offense i know he's
scored what 30 touchdowns over the last
two years but that's not a prime
position i just don't think when i look
at this roster that it's upgraded at all
over last year and to me there's still a
huge gap maybe bigger than even what
there was in the nfc championship game
between the packers and the buccaneers
i i continue to be fascinated the more i
think about it write about it talk about
it the decision not to do a full-blown
restructuring of aaron rodgers contract
to create
cap space
that could be used to
sign other players and that also
if they did the maximum
reconfiguration of his compensation this
year reduce his salary to the minimum of
1.075 million
it would have made it impossible for the
packers to trade him before june 1 of
2022 which would have gone a long way
toward giving him the security wants you
know usually that restructuring
is a benefit to the team
the player all you get out of it is we
create a cap space and i get all my
money now i was going to get it anyway
in this case given the magnitude of the
restructuring they could have done with
aaron rodgers it would have
created a cap charge of 33 million next
year not 17 million to trade him before
june 1 which would have given him i
think what he wanted so
they haven't
placated him
which i don't think they want to so i i
can't really fault them for that but
they've still got this vague
awkward issue with aaron rodgers
they've done nothing to bring in more
players that are going to help aaron
rodgers in the passing game yeah devin
functions is back he opted out last year
that really isn't a significant upgrade
for the green bay packers i i just i
think that if they do want
to take that next step and not just
fizzle out in the nfc championship after
a 13-3 season for the third straight
year they got to do more and there's
only so much they can do and you can say
oh they kept aaron jones well okay fine
but
again you're treading water
you're not
speeding up
they they are in a position where we
want to see them go next level because
they are right there on the cusp they
are in the process of knocking on the
door what are they going to do to kick
it in uh the 49ers were in that spot a
couple of years ago this is my other
choice and and the main reason i picked
the 49ers is
i don't believe they're content with a
quarterback position
and they so far have not addressed it
i know that they'll say all the right
things the players will say all the
right things whether it's george kittle
kyle use check or anyone else of course
they're going to say positive things
about their teammate john lynch will say
the right things kyle shanahan will say
the right things i think they continue
to search for someone who is dollar for
dollar better
than jimmy garoppolo they don't want to
pay him 25 million this year 25 million
is unjustified given the fact that he
has missed more games over the last
three seasons than he's won as a starter
during his time with the 49ers you can't
rely on him to stay healthy even if he
plays all games this year like he did in
2019 that's not going to prove me wrong
he's missed too many games between 2018
and 2020 the way the rules are aim
protecting quarterbacks
you got to be more reliable
by way of showing up and playing why do
you hate jimmy garoppolo i don't hate
jimmy garoppolo i like analyzing things
i like looking at a situation and saying
what can be done to make this team
better and shireen until they address
their quarterback situation the san
francisco 49ers still have work to do
i still think mike that we're going to
have some quarterback moves coming up
whether it's before the draft or during
the draft or soon after the draft
because if the jets take a quarterback i
mean you can almost count that sam sam
darnold's going to be elsewhere if they
trade him to the 49ers and jimmy
garoppolo is going to be elsewhere maybe
in new england wherever so i still think
we're going to have some moves deshawn
watson still could be moved at some
point before the end of this season so
we're going to see some of these
quarterbacks i think move around mike uh
before this is all said and done in 2021
yeah i think darnold is the guy that
they're watching and the jets first have
to decide they're going to move on from
him the jets have to decide whether
they're going to try to trade him i
continue to believe the window to watch
is the 18 hours from the completion of
round one to the draft to the start of
round two the josh rosen cycle that's
when i think we see sam darnold possibly
being traded and that's where the 49ers
could pick him up and then just like
that jimmy garoppolo would be gone i
don't think they trade him who's gonna
pay him 25 million dollars this year
he'd be cut there's no reason for him to
accept a pay cut to facilitate a trade
just say cut me and i'll pick my next
team so we'll we'll see how that all
plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports